if you need a Macbook for portability
but the built-in graphics options just
aren't powerful enough of your needs and
the GPU is the perfect answer simply by
an e GPU enclosure like this $300 razor
core X and stick in AMD graphics card in
for a major boost and graphics
performance now the only question
remains is which card do you buy well in
this video we're comparing the e GPU
performance of the top three AMD
graphics cards to see which one is the
best option for our test machine we've
got a 16 inch macbook pro that's almost
fully Specht out except for not having
64 gigs of ram and for the graphics
cards we've got the Vegas 64 which you
can get for $385 their Radeon 7 for $550
and the recently released 5700 XT for
370 dollars and I've got to say that
some of these results are very
surprising so stick around for all the
tests we'll have links to all these
cards down in the description so if this
video helps you make a decision you can
use those links for the best price on
each card Mac OS just received an update
that improved the performance of one of
these cards but as you'll see in a
minute it might not matter now before we
get into the graphics performance
testing I do want to mention that we're
using an older version of Final Cut Pro
since the latest one is using a brand
new metal 2 engine that isn't yet
optimized for EGP use but there is a new
version coming out very soon so
hopefully it should fix that getting
right into it with Geekbench 5s metal
tests the Radeon 7 comes out ahead but
not by that much considering the higher
price tag we were also expecting a bit
more power out of the 5700 XT but it
turns out that there are still some
driver issues that don't allow it to
reach full performance unless you
connect multiple monitors at once with
various configurations MacRumors forum
user BS beamer was able to get metal
scores as high as 70 thousand with the
5700 XT using headless adapters which
tricked the system into thinking there
is a display connected when there really
isn't
we ended up connecting two displays and
we got a metal score of 65 thousand much
better than we were able to get
previously so if you don't have two
displays to connect
- you're a GPU or if you don't want to
use external displays at all you can
order a couple of those headless
adapters using the links in the
description below this will get you
better performance until Apple updates
the drivers for the 5700 XC shortly for
example in the Bruce X benchmark in
Final Cut Pro 10 using dual monitors
with the 5700 XT saved us two seconds
over the card by itself which was
already surprisingly good
we then stabilized a 30 second 60 p c200
bra clip and once again the dual
monitors or headless adaptive solution
helped the 5700 XT beat out the rest of
the cards by a few seconds however in
our five-minute 4k h.264 export test
using dual monitors didn't help at all
in fact the Radeon seven was actually
the winner in this test now on to
exporting a five-minute Canon raw 6 EP
clip the 5700 XT finished the fastest
regardless of whether we're using dual
displays are not so it seems like it's a
hit or miss on whether dual displays
will help we also tested the timeline
playback of the same Canon raw clip and
this time using two monitors gave us a
massive boost in frames per second
specifically 12 more FPS compared to
using one monitor which was already
performing the best we then took that
same Canon raw clip and imported it into
DaVinci Resolve 16 because it can
harness a GPUs very well as long as you
go into the Preferences and manually
enable the e GPU for rendering and in
this test we got an extra 8 fps in the
timeline using dual monitors with the
5700 XT compared to the other cars which
shows that the benefits are not only
limited to Final Cut Pro but in
exporting once again we didn't see any
speed improvements with the extra
display but it's still quite a lot
faster than the other cards we then
tested 4k black magic rod noise
reduction in the 5700 XT matches the
Radeon 7 for having the best performance
now going back to Final Cut Pro we
exported an 8k red raw clip into 4k and
this time the Radeon 7 was the clear
winner quite a lot faster than the 5700
XT with the single monitor
not too far ahead of the dual monitor
setup the reason the seven performed so
well in this test is because it has 16
gigs of VRAM compared to 8 on the other
cards so it seems like the only reason
you should buy the 7 is if you
absolutely know you need as much B RAM
as possible but even then I would still
recommend the 5700 XT because it was the
winner in the rest of the test which is
surprising considering it's the cheapest
card out of the bunch
and finally we tested unit ins heaven
benchmark to simulate real-world gaming
performance in the 57 beat out the rest
of the cards yet again the reason we
think is faster is because it's using
AMD's latest Navi technology which comes
with a lot of improvements including
hardware encoders that encode video
footage faster than the older cards we
tested in this video and on top of that
we have one major reason why we think
the 5700 XT is gonna get even faster
very soon Apple is currently working on
releasing the W 5700 X graphics option
for their mac pro which is basically the
same card as the 5700 XT so that means
that when they release that card for the
Mac Pro they'll also update the drivers
as well and the 57 should get a decent
performance boost as well as fixing the
issues with the drivers now the Radeon 7
and Vegas 64 cards are now so old that
we don't expect Apple to improve the
drivers on these cards any more so with
that let's answer the original question
which graphics card should you buy for
your EGP you set up 100% no doubt about
it by the 5700 XT especially while it's
on sale for three hundred and seventy
dollars on Amazon using the link in the
description below and to deal with the
driver issues and tell the upcoming
update we'll have links to the headless
adapters as well the 5700 XT will get
you great performance right now and even
better performance later if this video
helped you out
tap the like button click the circle
about to subscribe and check out one of
those 2 videos right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next one
[Music]